uh hi there this is steve kaufman
um you know this is a bit of an
experiment i'm in my hotel room in
prague
the lighting is not very good i find
that if i stand up it's actually a bit
lighter but it's still going to be
dark um the internet connection isn't
great here so i don't know if i'll be
able to upload this video to youtube but
obviously if if it gets through and
you're walking watching it then i did
get through
so
i wanted to provide an interim report on
my five days to fluency here in prague
on how i'm doing
well i've had a quite a hectic
stay
i it was a long flight from montreal
because i'm traveling on point so the
connections are aren't always that
convenient so i had a long layover in
london heathrow i didn't get in here
uh until at seven o'clock at night or so
uh the taxi that i took from the airport
although i had been warned that the taxi
drivers can sometimes want to take you
for a ride here i had the nicest taxi
driver and we spoke checked the whole
way in
and i said wow this is great because i
had also heard that
czech people are likely to speak to in
english and not in check even if you try
to speak to them and check so the taxi
driver was great
then i arrived at the hotel i said the
dobry vacher as i arrived good evening
in check and the lady there very kindly
uh you know and patiently uh dealt with
me in check so i walked up to my room
and i said wow this is great
however i must say that since that time
just about everybody i talked to
including
um policemen that i'm asking
instructions from
everybody answers in english like i was
eight out of 10 people
so in terms of just randomly
using the language
um yeah maybe seven out of ten reply in
english three out of ten you're able to
speak some check however
uh you know i was having lunch in a
small uh czech restaurant and uh well i
wasn't that small actually it's a it's
opposite the uh
naruto lord of opposite the national
theater and of course the place was full
so i had to sit down with
other people
and there were two
ladies there and so i started up a
conversation and we had a great
conversation so there you go uh it is
possible on occasion to stripe up strike
up conversations with random people i
have had two lessons a day here an hour
in the morning and an hour half in the
afternoon
with the two of my tutors so that's kind
of my
guaranteed daily check
and then the
the first day that i was here which was
tuesday night the first full day uh we
had a
20 somehow more than 20 people showed up
for our meetup at the uh
novo mizki uh pivovar
and i have some video of that and uh if
i can figure out how to get it on to
youtube youtube i'm going to for some
reason the file seems very long but
we'll figure it out at any rate that was
solid check for a good four hours or so
so that first day was a lot of check uh
the second day a little bit less but i
had to run some errands and do some
things
but today i had my lesson this morning
i'm having lunch with one of the people
who
came and i must say all the people who
came to the dinner were
keeners on learning language people who
follow me here on youtube
many of them spoke several languages
one of them mikhail
said you know if you have time give me a
call we'll have lunch he's a lawyer here
in prague so we're going to have lunch
in a couple of hours
and then we're meeting again tonight
with zdeniak who has come up from bruno
with his girlfriend and yarda is going
to be with me again he was there of
course tuesday night and
there was another gentleman i think
ronald was his name who teaches four
different languages and he and possibly
another person are going to come so
we'll have another solid check evening
tonight
tomorrow i'm invited by gabriella and
jan to their home at night that'll be
some solid check uh plus uh we're having
lunch with zuzana and her husband are
gonna visit a museum uh we'll see how
much check we get in there so yeah i'm
getting enough opportunity but but the
bigger thing is that just
i think the biggest thing of all is like
how much i will improve i don't know
however the
sense of satisfaction from the minute i
got on the plane in london and they made
the public address system on the
airplane in check and i understood what
they were saying that's a wonderful
feeling uh to fly into a place and all
of a sudden you know what they're saying
everything around me i understand i can
read it i can read the signs
if i have to for example i got on the
tramway uh and the conductor said you
know you can't buy tickets here and i
said well where do i buy them he says i
don't know you get a lot of that here
you know where i don't know
okay so but then i go ask a few people
on the street and they spoke to me and
checked and directed me finally to a
place where i could buy the ticket for
the tramway a very handy weather
excellent system i should say again that
my morning my morning uh the classes are
the best because my hotel is right by
the charles
bridge
and the charles bridge is probably the
most international place in the world
you hear every possible language there
and it's just chock-a-block
with tourists but at seven in the
morning as i walk across the bridge it's
just spectacular the sun is rising
there's no one on the bridge i see all
of prague in front of me it's just it's
just wonderful and spectacular uh but i
was going to say the biggest advantage
of
if you remember my strategy
five days to fluency the whole idea is
that you plan for this
five days which hopefully for most
people is longer than five days but i
only have five days so you prepare for
this is my goal i have to be functional
when i get there in six months in a year
however long you give yourself
and so then i did a lot of listening and
reading built up my vocabulary with two
months to go i started
increasing you know the frequency of my
online discussions with my tutors so
when i get here i can function now i
wouldn't call myself fluent
uh although i'm going to put up some
videos of me speaking check but i'm
comfortable i understand what people
sing are saying to me i understand
conversations uh and that's a wonderful
feeling i think with that kind of a base
it doesn't take you long
to start using it even though of course
you stumble and make
all kinds of grammatical mistakes when
speaking the language
uh i think it it takes you to a new
level but i think the impact is not
immediate i don't think you come here
and in three days bingo you're fluent
but i think it what i feel about it is
that it it puts you in a different state
you've lived now in the language for
five days it's no longer something
that's artificial
you've been immersed to it in it
and i think you come away with that with
a lot of things that are going to
continue to grow with you a different
attitude to the language because you've
known you now know that you can actually
function in the language
um
and i think uh yeah
the effects will be felt over a longer
period of time the other thing you of
course notice is that having done a lot
of listening to radio and things about
history and stuff you're missing the
day-to-day um the day-to-day day-to-day
words
uh i met this american girl in the
bookstore
and
she had a lot of the day-to-day language
but she said that she was very afraid to
go to
the countryside where
people don't speak english because she's
afraid that she might be in a situation
where she just couldn't find her way
back or that there would be no one there
who would understand what she was saying
or that she wouldn't understand and i
don't have that fear at all because i
understand what people are saying so i
might have difficulty i might be missing
a few words very common words in fact
that i haven't come across
but i'm totally comfortable that i
understand what people are saying and i
could stumble my way through to explain
anything that i need to explain but
that's certainly not fluency anyway just
a short term uh here uh report and we'll
see we can load this video up and i
pardon i apologize for the lighting here
in my room thank you for listening and
bye for oh one very important thing all
those people who came to the dinner
uh and many of them expressed the desire
to get together again even when i'm not
here of course there's a little group of
keen language learners a group of
linkers and of course i tremendously
encourage that we didn't have all have a
chance to exchange emails if all the
people who are there or anybody else who
wants to be part
uh of a group whether in prague or
really anywhere send me your email at
steveatlinklingq.com
send me your email and i will find a way
to share these emails around everyone
that sends me an email so if you're at
the dinner or you want to belong to a
group of language cleaners or linkers
please send me your email at steve link
lingq dot com thank you bye